CNN just getting new and
exclusive video of the former president.
He is at his resort
in south Florida tonight,
just hours away from being criminally
arraigned on.
37 counts,
criminal counts
related to his handling
of classified
documents, dissemination
of those documents, retention
and obstruction.
Randi Kaye is OUTFRONT live from Florida.
And Randi,
what is Trump
doing on the eve of this
court appearance,
which any lawyer will tell
you should now be the single
most important thing in his life?
Absolutely.
Aaron,
he arrived
here at his resort
in Doral, Florida, about three
30 this afternoon or so.
He went upstairs
with his son and his team of lawyers
and the rest of his entourage.
And we hadn't seen him
until just about 7:00
where I can show you
this video
that I just got out of him
in the lobby
coming down the elevator to go to dinner
with many in his team
at the restaurant in in the Doral Resort.
His son, Eric had gone in there
about a half an hour before
with a bunch of individuals.
He was obviously meeting him.
And there were a lot of people
outside the restaurant,
many of whom were fans.
They were shouting to him, Mr.
President, Mr. President, we're with you.
We stand by you. We love you.
How do you feel about tomorrow?
He did some thumbs up action
with the rest of them,
and then he stopped.
Some people said,
can we take some pictures
with you and Aaron?
He actually
paused and took some pictures
with some people.
Listen to what they did for a living.
And then he went on his way to the back
room of the restaurant
where he was going to dine
with his family,
with his son, Eric,
and the rest of his team.
But it was interesting just to see
he seemed to be in good spirits
earlier in the day.
He seemed a bit somber,
said to everybody, how are you doing?
But was much more much quieter.
And this time around, he was cheery
and taking pictures
and had a very confident air
about him on the eve of
what is going to be a very,
very critical day for Mr.
Trump. Certainly.
It certainly is.
Thank you very much, Randi.
And OUTFRONT
now, Van Jones,
Alyssa Farah Griffin, Laura
Coates and Scott Jennings.
So let's let's just
look at that video again.
It is interesting
because, you know,
you've got the people at the restaurant,
you know, Mr. President, Mr.
President,
you know, supporting him, taking pictures
with him.
And it's interesting
when Randi contrasts
the kind of confidence he's now exuding
versus
more solemnity earlier in the day
that he just feeds off a moment
like this. It's like oxygen, right?
This is what gives him life.
And by the way, Doral
is sort of like a resort.
So there's people there who are golfing
who go and stay there,
spend a lot of money
in hopes of seeing him, in hopes
of getting a selfie with him.
This isn't unlike the prior arraignment
and the fact that we're talking
about a second arraignment
for a former president
is historic in itself.
But he really did project confidence
the night before.
I think tomorrow
you're going to see a president
that, again, is dealing with the weight
of what happened in the moment.
And then he is going to go out
and give a campaign speech
and it's going to be fire fury.
The Department of Justice,
the Democrats are coming after us.
It's not me.
This is all part of kind of his plan.
And I'm not sure it
majorly shifts anything for him at this.
No.
And it's just the images
that he wants, right.
That he wants to look like this guy.
Look, I'm going into my club.
We now have a playbook
for how the president,
the former president gets indicted
and what he does the day before.
What he does. They are this is crazy.
This is crazy.
When you put it that way, like
this is not normal, guys.
This is weird.
So we know that he's going to be
you know, tomorrow
he'll be somber in court
and he's going to go give big
and we'll produce again in Georgia.
This is
this is not the Republican Party
needs to look around
for somebody else to represent.
That's all happening.
So, Laura,
let me just
I'm actually just want to pull
some notes out from the conversation
I had
with Tim Pawlenty,
who was on the other day.
His comment right
about the moment
that the former president is in,
that this has to be the single
most important thing in your life.
It is a perilous place to be.
Does the former president get that?
He should.
I mean,
there is a tremendous amount of weight
to have your name
at the other side of United States
versus now.
Of course,
there's been a lot of commentary about
how we have to
justice systems in America,
apparently only
when it respects Donald Trump.
We've had a differentiation
for a very long time.
And people are looking at
now the presumption of innocence,
meaning the presumption
of corruption by the DOJ.
But that's not actually the case here.
The read
this has to be a singular focus
is because every single word he says
will be used against him
in a court of law.
Not might not.
There's a chance
will be the indictment itself
already listed from 2016.
They are intending for him
to make some missteps.
All of this has been
a self-inflicted wound.
And guess what?
They'll be predictably others.
And so the focus has to be
on the gravitas of this, but also about
how do you work with your counsel or to
on the one
hand have the bravado
you're speaking about to be as verbose
as he's been to follow his own blueprint
and also be able to defend his actions.
I mean, I just want to read something.
Is this.
This is a little game
I'm going to ask you,
who said these things?
Are you ready for my little game?
I mean, she should be going to jail.
I mean, I don't know
what the hell's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
She did so knowing full
well it would put American lives at risk
by making classified information
highly vulnerable to foreign hacking.
Hillary's private emails,
the email scandal
which put out
classified information
within reach of our enemies,
disqualifies her from the presidency.
One guess.
Okay, Trump.
All right.
So, I mean,
I was going to say, Van, so
but I remember it was
does this does the gravity of this?
Let me ask the question to you
a little bit differently.
Does anyone around him
understand the gravity of this,
like in his interest,
his son Eric,
the people that he with tonight?
Or do they
all just, you know,
sort of the emperor has no clothes
and just telling what he wants to hear?
Yeah, that's a great question because
they've got two major life
events going on.
One is keeping him out of jail
at his age.
And the other, of course, is
perhaps their best legal strategy slash
political strategy,
which is to win the election.
And I mean,
these are all encompassing things,
fighting for your life in court,
fighting for your life.
Politically, I mean, these
these things are all consuming and so
the gravity of both of them are enormous.
You know, everybody
sort of laughed off
the New York indictment,
which I know is
scheduled to go to trial early next year.
You can't laugh.
You just can't laugh this off
when you look at the evidence.
And every single lawyer, including people
like Jonathan Turley,
who's a conservative lawyer
that's defended
Donald Trump, is on television saying, f
you are in trouble here.
You cannot laugh it off.
You have to take it seriously,
because if he doesn't win the presidency
and he does go to trial,
you you know, he's in real jeopardy.
Well, and by the way, let's remember,
he announced his candidacy
incredibly early,
historically early
for a primary to announce.
And I think a large part of
it was because he knew
that this could be coming.
And it's a way to say I'm a candidate.
This is a witch hunt.
And in fact, if he gets the nomination
and goes on to be elected, president,
that's the best legal backstop
that he has.
But I think this is a strategy
they've been working
with from the outset.
It really pulls it, though.
I mean,
if he were to be become
the United States it's
not as if the case just goes away.
The other
the opinion is that you cannot indict
a sitting president.
And the idea of having the distraction,
so to speak, of federal prosecution
would be told
if you were actually in office,
it would obliterate the entire case
if he were actually to be there.
But to the larger point here as well,
consider this.
Up till now,
Republicans have criticized him
for airing past grievances.
The re litigation of 2020.
This does
provide him
a brand new grievance
about post-presidential conduct
And I wonder
if there is some warped sense of reality
to suggest that.
Okay.
Well,
you didn't want me to look at the past.
How about right now?
Well, that actually moves the needle
for the DOJ,
of course, is not going to happen.
Yeah.
In general,
I like it when people run for president
to save the country
and not to save themselves
because I'm old fashioned in that regard.
And so, you know,
it's really I do think he ran very early.
I mean, as soon as the midterms is over,
I ran for president.
You're trying to get ahead.
Not a crisis for the country.
Your leadership
trying to get ahead
of all these indictments
and I hope people don't keep falling for.
There was
some polling from CBS this weekend
that indicated Republican primary voters
strongly prefer that
he talk
most about his plans
for the country in another term.
They were far less interested
in talking about investigations
or relitigating the 2020 election.
This thing being this thing
being on the front burner.
Of course, he's
going to end his speech in Georgia
this weekend.
He talked for 40 minutes or something
about about this stuff.
And so
there is a messaging challenge in this
and that
I guess the possibility exists
Republican primary voters
might start wondering,
do you really have a plan
for the next war?
I waited to go to this
rally and I just had to listen to this.
I mean, I don't know.
All right. Thank you. All very much.